suite de notre série sur les îles
aujourd'hui l'île de sein au large de la
pointe sud de la bretagne
l'un des personnages les plus importants
de lindsay le gardien du phare dans une
région particulièrement dangereuse pour
la navigation maryse burgot eric cherche
c'est pas folichon folichon vous voyez
de temps et et à la brume c'est vraiment
la poisse et on voit pas grand chose la
visibilité vraiment nul jarret et puis
la température comme
ferai un petit vent de wes n'auront à
troyes lorient la journée du gardien de
phare de l'île de sein commence toujours
avec les mêmes mots ceux de la météo
marine informations précieuses aux
navigateurs qui passeront ce matin le
célèbre et redouté rap st le phare de
l'île sera l'un de leur repaire les plus
fiables et depuis deux ans c'est entre
autres noël fouquet qui veille au bon
fonctionnement de cette sentinelle des
mers un véritable choix de vie puisque
quinze jours par mois
il lui faut demeurer sur l'île cette
larme de terre d'un kilomètre carré ne
compte pas plus de 200 habitants l'hiver
une île qui se mérite et ne se vante pas
au premier venu
c'est par le puma les gens sont francky
peut renfermer sur eux même s'essayer à
la ils sont un petit peu quand il voit
une personne étrangère à lille débarquer
chez eux bon
il sourit suspecte un petit peu comme
quoi la cccc étrangers qui débarquent
donc noël fouquet est né sur l'île de
sein et s'il ne vit pas ici en
permanence lui ne sera jamais considéré
comme un étranger
quelques mots échangés sur le cac des
paimpolais avant de reprendre un peu de
hauteur dans le phare à l'autre bout de
l'île le forcée car 42 mètres de haut
donc pour y accéder au sommet il ya il
faut emprunter 249 marche est bon il
nous arrive de monter de temps en temps
quand même 1 2 3 francs la semaine 1
ces dernières années le métier a bien
changé noël fouquet est en fait
aujourd'hui essentiellement chargée de
l'entretien des machines sous les îles
bretonnes comme partout ailleurs en
france les far ont tous été
progressivement automatisés l'île de
sein n'a pas été épargné par ce vent de
la modernité